what we found in this research and we
did all kinds of strategy sessions you
know focus groups and interviews with
talent managers there were eight things
you could do to pump up morale you know
massively improve motivation and
actually figure out how to retain and
fully utilize you know the talent you
have and they range from involving them
in recreating pride and purpose in terms
of the mission of your company because
you know in some of our more broken
sectors you just think of financial
services for instance there's a
tremendous sense that the entire
business model is broken and where'd you
go next for you know robust profits but
if you're also being frozen out and not
talked to were not involved in the
process you yourself don't feel any
ownership in terms of where the company
may or may not be going so involving
your top talent in the restructuring
refocusing recreation of purpose and
mission very important so it ranges from
that to figuring out how to help people
your top people and also yourself with
the body blows there's tremendous impact
on health and well-being that's gone on
in this recession and we've measured a
lot of this whether it's depression or
you know compromised immune systems
there are really egregious impact on the
body that has gone on in this you know
last twelve month period so again you
know Ernst & Young has an amazing
program called pinnacles which is really
reaching out and helping their top
professionals to work on their wellness
and their vitality and resilience and
that I think is particularly valuable
this year so these eight interventions
are
think all of them have you know many
case examples they are things that
companies are trying but it's about you
know feeding the cell restoring the
spirits you know knitting together the
motivation of the folks that you are
totally reliant on for the next day